It's not surprising...
...that a lot of people buy into this corporate myth that you have got to be mean to win.
Maybe you don't even know a lot of nice people that are successful but let me ask you this.
Have you ever met a mean, successful person who was happy?
'Cause that's important too.
Let me give you an example of one who meets that test,...
... Dwight Eisenhower, former President, former leader of our armed forces,...
...Patton and MacArthur willingly reported to him because of phrases like, "I like Ike,"...
...not born in politics but born on the battlefield...
...by young men willing to risk their lives for this highly likable leader.
As much as that was true in Eisenhower's day in the 21st century, it's more important than ever.
Kids of today like my 20-year-old, they believe financial freedom has changed.
To them, financial freedom is not about being debt-free,...
...financial freedom is freedom not to work for a jerk.
Besides, anybody knows that when you write a great story,...
...you make the bad guy successful till about the middle of the movie,...
...but you show me any bad guy that makes it till the end of the movie...
...who's happy and successful, there you go.